okay I think the microphone is on nobody
actually knows for sure what we'll do
this okay I think we have like two
missions left so it might as well just
[ __ ] do it allows that I don't
remember where we are a family remember
the controls sir he's gone
ah yes [ __ ] [ __ ]
Wow that I could just get hurt from it
oh [ __ ]
okay uh we gotta kick Yelland it oh [ __ ]
wait why is the water drain now [ __ ] it
[ __ ] why is that on rocket launcher
[ __ ] a why is it still a Russell
under Oh Kyle over okay wait under
attack
so you came back to Connie nas with you
standing oh yeah okay this we got [ __ ]
sir
Wow
okay why libraries books espera said
whatever they want that's cool [ __ ]
hell are you making an entrance
listen most courses should you take it
Anya so Sharon said I'm a body to have
been transported that that says conquer
you doing virgins are working what's
Tricia pletely late near Bosco there's
one helicopter still on the growth in
our Hanna if you hurry we can take a bar
get people is focus it Fergus out okay
you mean she shot holy [ __ ] I took a
lotta arrow is there still
and I'll [ __ ] now we'll get the
hangers this way all they shed yeah
[ __ ] pieces okay well I gotta use
this assault rifle then you know step
dick you [ __ ] say tap out app app
a lot of blood here here's the one thing
that I hide
oh they did last night it's got to be
like health and [ __ ] here tonight
Oh gadget the Canton hearin test I got
to go up but let me just check make sure
not missing a fog and help is it bad
that things like on fire
got to unless is next to godliness yeah
yeah
well yeah whoa no forever at it when I'm
gonna be able to use this okay Oh what
the [ __ ] I want to suck force damaged
forever how do you arrive everything in
accordance with the numbers this day the
number of consequence is 19 applying why
not mass to square each and every one on
our side must be fit nicely what
umbrella or NASA and then if you win
I've been proficient with what you've
got to me and living in the stack I
thank you I can't remember if I pay
attention thank the man that is my face
I have accumulated an addition of seven
two other means prior to this day among
the whole body depart for render
everything she's a violet my model the
model is loyal for universal credit you
asked me to ban against the laws of
nature don't you see the road in front
of you is long and so on I wonder how
you could mine is at its end on this day
I am glad
listen she didn't make it
she would turn my suit if I want that's
20 dead and they're like these are a mo
[ __ ] haters force death let's go
should be one entryway to the hangar
through sewage tunnel I think be careful
like this place is proving with the
ugliest [ __ ] masses you've ever seen
just get everything set up this goes to
this and as guys notice back yet and
their mark at what the [ __ ] is shooting
okay I gotta figure out what I'm doing
that's what I shoulda got em oh yeah
[ __ ] keep movin alright where the [ __ ]
am I now like no ammo what is that I got
a fall already attached or something
holy [ __ ] how do I know that what's the
[ __ ]
maybe you could do something about this
Nazi problems there try not to get
Fergus killed please
he's also animal and essentially
defenseless
yeah yeah out out
Wow [ __ ] an hey hey
now
[ __ ] egg
all right let's go
where were you
hi baby
alright exit level
[Music]
there's a [ __ ] chance let's go okay
beta then let's give you a shot oh yeah
he's definitely a machine which on
purpose okay and my load on the body you
know
I can't oh hey there's that we own that
what are you doing Anya tagging a dream
like this wake up to reality sometimes
true feeling the remember what you're
fighting for
[Music]
it's time from what we know this has
compound prisoners are kept on the lower
levels close to the experimental level
our timing needs to be perfect we have
the nuclear decryption keys now at
element deep surface real close to the
compound
you [ __ ] polar AC analog with a
cannon gets a the compound fast as you
can they'll be returning fire so we'll
need two days again before the euro gets
gummed up another which will pull back
to a safe distance when you're inside
get down to the lower level and about
300 visitors we send in a helicopter
once everyone is safely in the air we
prime the nuclear warheads fire the
atomic bombs level the whole site people
ben'll normal death head
pocket how much is vomit from here it's
all done laughable to self you
magnificent come yeah yes max I'm
wearing all right it's always on [ __ ]
red like they gave me no oxygen for this
[ __ ] mission okay well that's good
what's going on here okay here we go
why do I feel [ __ ] like sick of this
[ __ ] live on a weapon oh wait alright
let me stop this here